deuxième victoire de l'équipe de france
de rugby dans le tournoi des cinq
nations france 19 angleterre 15
rencontres difficiles mais très bel
essai de philippe sella le brésil
suspend le paiement des intérêts de sa
dette extérieure la crise économique
l'empêchent de rembourser l'équivalent
de plus de 420 milliards de francs 48
heures avant la première audience du
procès de georges ibrahim abdallah à
paris en quête antenne de hervé brusini
dominicaine sur les fractions armées
révolutionnaires libanaises dort
abdallah serait le chef présumé
aujourd'hui samedi 21 février 1987
nouvelle journée de détention pour les
otages français au liban marcel fontaine
et marcel carton
jean paul kauffmann jean louis normandin
antenne 2 n'ont toujours pas été libérés
bonsoir 19 15 2 essais français et
deuxième victoire pour le quinze
tricolore dans ce tournoi des cinq
nations 87 pour l'instant le contrat est
rempli
mais dieu que ce fut difficile en
première mi temps l'équipe de france a
connu de grosses difficultés face aux
offensives anglaises et au jeu pour le
moins viril de leurs adversaires on
retiendra de ce match disputé à
twickenham et retransmis en direct cet
après midi sur antenne 2 un moment
formidable
l'essai marqué par philippe sella
commentaires lionel chamoulaud un coq
français fier mais qui a souffert
aujourd'hui à twickenham
comme d'habitude larbitre à bien
surveiller les indisciplinés joueurs
français résultat après seulement 12
minutes de jeu 3 pénalité sifflée par
monsieur fleming et trois réussites de
l'ariège marcus pose avec le vent 9 à 0
défense et punis dès le début du match
c'est devenu une habitude
jouons un peu comme commentaire c'est
avec handicap
nous avions prévu se lavent puisque
signe le vent soufflait très fort à
l'avantagé des anglais daniel libre
qu'avait décidé de jouer contre levante
tout à fait logiquement d'ailleurs et
nous pensions que si nous n'étions
menait de dix points à la mi temps nous
avions toutes nos chances pour ne pas
être totalement décramponner les
français vont bien réagir
une mêlée solide une ouverture de pierre
berbizier sur mesnel qui assurent le
drop 9 à 3 seulement ce genre d'exercice
les anglais savent aussi le faire la
preuve avec rob andrew score à la pause
12 à 3 pour les britanniques
deuxième période les français
s'installent dans le camp britannique
berbizier pour mesnel une combinaison
avec charvet qui croisent à l'intérieur
et lance éric champlain champ puis ban
ovale qui va entre les poteaux vers ont
réussi la transformation 12 à 12 et puis
le grand moment du match 65e minute le
pack anglais gagnent la balle il veut
transmettre à angres ou mais c'est là
surgit et on n'arrête pas philippe sella
lancé harrison et rose ont savent
quelque chose
encore un essai historique pour la
jeunesse
pour moi c'est fantastique c'est le rêve
vers la forêt réalité puisque j'ai
retrouvé mes copains derrière la ligne
et j'ai dit c'est que c'est sous ces
fous je pense une belle interception
j'ai bien anticiper sur la longue pause
entre deux joueurs anglais j'ai pu
ensuite c'était pas si facile que ça
j'avais
l'ailier droit qui me revenait en
travers l'ariège qui était face à moi
j'ai hésité à taper par dessus l'arrière
et puis
on diriger sur vers la tribune
présidentielle j'ai préféré profiter et
accélérer à nouveau
score final 19 à 15 les français sont en
route pour le grand chelem prochain
match contre l'ecosse une 7 mars au parc
des princes
il y avait une autre rencontre cecos
irlande les écossais ont battu l'irlande
16 à 12
les anglais devait donc se racheter
d'une première défaite face à l'irlande
il ya quinze jours le public anglais a
porté son équipe allant jusqu à souffler
souffler très fort pour pousser en mêlée
dans le stade de twickenham voyez le
reportage réalisé par jean ma mère et
marcel martin à twickenham le match
commence dès 11 heures du matin
banquet hivernale par 0-2 grimm et
alcool à réchauffer partout dans les
coffrets sur les tables nul n'y échappe
même les français pour qui ce genre de
festin est devenue une intéressante
tradition derniers salons locaux dernier
salon lancé ses pronostics le monde ne
s'est il pas toujours refait derrière
une bonne bouteille
je pense que c'est l'angleterre quel
score combien qu'elles disent que brice
brahma je pense que aujourd'hui les
français sont les meilleurs
les onglets fair-play britannique et
sécurité discrète dans le temple de
fictionnelle à l'extérieur et à
l'intérieur
recueillement alors des ihm
et chauvigny sont exacerbées
silence pour un tiers français sur le
poteau
hurlements dans la même chose du côté
emmener
malheureusement aujourd'hui le héron
dette et francette et philippe sella
pour un set corani c'est qu'il qualifie
du bout du monde et le bout du monde
aujourd'hui c'était truqué nam au liban
pour mettre un terme aux affrontements
dans le quartier musulman de beyrouth
qui depuis une semaine ont fait 200
morts et 400 blessés
cinq dirigeants libanais musulmans ont
demandé à la syrie une aide militaire le
président du liban
amine gemayel n'a pas été contacté tout
s'est décidé à damas commentaires pierre
serra c'est au cours de cette réunion
qui s'est tenue hier damas donc la
décision était prise autour du président
syrien hafez el-assad
les ministres musulmans libanais les
chefs de milice
les frères ennemis notamment nabih berri
et le shit et walid joumblatt le druze
dont les milices s'affronter s'écharpent
depuis cinq jours une décision imposée
par damas donc le retour en force de
l'armée syrienne à beyrouth ouest pour
rétablir l'ordre
les syriens ont commencé à rassembler
entre 3 et 4000 hommes sur des chars
mais leur entrée dans la vie pourrait
avoir lieu cette nuit ou de bain ce
n'est pas facile en effet car la
situation est très compliquée pour
simplifier je dirais qu'il ya deux
hypothèses est une réalité première
hypothèse
damas a tout manigancé jours les uns
contre les autres pour apparaître comme
le seul recours capable de rétablir le
calme
sinon la paix deuxième hypothèse qui se
ne paraît plus vraisemblable damas a
poussé le mouvement chiite amal en
l'aidant massivement à faire le sale
boulot pour parvenir à une mainmise
totale sur beyrouth ouest pour cela il
fallait d'abord éliminer les forces
palestiniennes ou la guerre des camps et
dans un deuxième temps qui ne s'est pas
produit à faiblir sinon anéantir le
hezbollah le parti de dieu et donc l'
influence iranienne et ça n'a pas marché
alors la réalité aujourd'hui c'est que
cinq ans après avoir quitté beyrouth la
pression de l'armée israélienne en jeu à
81,2 eh bien les syriens sont de retour
même s'ils décident à entrer dans
beyrouth où chaque l'uni jusqu'à ce soir
tu encore à coups de canon d'assurer ses
positions les heures qui viennent vont
être décisives ou bien les syriens dans
la foulée vont mettre le paquet pour
terminer le travail
ammann n'a pas pu mener à son terme ou
bien ils se contentent d'arrêter les
combats entre leurs alliés chiites et
druzes avec une incertitude de taille
car élite
houle peuvent-ils réellement y parvenir
dans le terrain ou sur un terrain aussi
mouvant et si d'aventuré ils réussissent
et bien accepteront ils un jour de
repartir
c'est là le problème le président du
brésil josé sarney a décidé de suspendre
jusqu'à nouvel ordre le paiement des
intérêts de la dette extérieure du
brésil cette dette la plus élevée des
pays en développement équivaut à plus de
420 milliards de francs le brésil veut
renégocier avec les banquiers étrangers
la situation économique et sociale
brazil and est en péril reconnaît
monsieur sarney qui veut éviter une
période d'instabilité politique et de
récession
explication gérard leclerc le
gouvernement brésilien réuni au grand
complet pour constater que le pays est
au bord de la faillite
face à un endettement colossal de 108
milliards de dollars les réserves de
change ne représente plus que trois mois
d'importations
la balance commerciale est l équilibre
quand elles devraient dégager 12
milliards de dollars pour payer les
seuls intérêts de la dette
dans la soirée le président josé sarney
annonce solennellement que le brésil
suspens le remboursement de la dette
jusqu'à son rééchelonnement par les
grandes banques
nous ne pouvons pas payer la dette avec
la fin du peuple affirme le président en
présentant que même de nouvelles mesures
de rigueur
cela fait cinq ans que le pays se débat
dans l'endettement contracté à l'époque
du miracle brésilien au plan d'austérité
imposé par le fmi et qui ont accru le
chômage et la pauvreté a succédé le plan
crouzado qui a relancé l'inflation est
vidé les caisses de l'état une situation
inextricable qui n'est pas propre au
brésil et dans laquelle les pays
occidentaux ont leur responsabilité
si ces pays se sont si fortement endetté
où sont les responsabilités si ce n'est
en fait chez ceux qui leur ont prêté et
souvent qui les ont encouragés et poussé
entreprises financier états à s'endetter
au delà du raisonnable car
l'étranglement par la dette ne concerne
pas le seul brésil avec la crise et la
baisse de l'aide des nations
industrialisées ce sont plus de mille
milliards de dollars de dette compte
accumulé les pays en voie de
développement
l'argentine et le pérou menace à leur
tour de ne plus rembourser
de quoi faire exploser le système
financier international
pour les experts il n'y a qu'une
solution relancer l'économie mondiale
l'avoine sortie
optimiste si vous voulez c'est qu'ils y
ait une reprise la croissance économique
une accélération de la croissance
économique dans la pme sur dix est une
contrôle sur les tendances
protectionnistes qu'on est bien utilisé
qui permettrait une expansion plus
rapide du canadien national et en
particulier des exportations des pays en
voie de développement
pourquoi parce que c'est les
exportations qui permet de de rembourser
la dette avec les noms de son oratoire
le brésil propulse l'endettement du
tiers-monde et la relance des économies
au centre des débats du groupe des
sectes cette décision brésilienne de
suspendre le paiement de sa dette
extérieure était prise à la veille de la
réunion à paris des ministres des
finances et gouverneurs des banques
centrales de sept pays principaux pays
démocratiques industrialisés cela ne
peut qu'accroître l'inquiétude des
économistes qui devront étudier les
moyens de stabiliser les taux de change
monétaires dès cet après-midi première
réunion informelle à cinq états unis
japon allemagne de l'ouest
grande-bretagne et france a eu lieu
demain l'italie et le canada seront
présents commentaires philippe sassier 6
rue de révolus au siège du ministère des
finances que se sont retrouvés cet après
midi les ministres des finances des cinq
pays les plus riches du monde
à 3 heures précises arrive la délégation
japonaise dès hier le japon a fait un
geste de bonne volonté en baissant le
niveau de ses taux d'intérêt afin
d'accroître un petit peu le rythme de la
croissance économique japonaise
les journalistes présents n'obtiendront
aucune déclaration et dossiers qui vont
être abordés monnaies coopération
économique internationale et bien
évidemment dette du tiers-monde à la
suite des décisions brésiliennes ont
tous une importance capitale
ministres et experts s'engouffre dans le
ministère où les actants edouard
balladur
car la france a la tâche redoutable
d'assurer la présidence de cette réunion
demain autour de la table des
négociations ils seront sept
et c'est au milieu de l'après midi on
devrait connaître leur décision
toutes les pièces de ce cannes
économistes appellent la bombe atomique
monétaires seront sur cette table car le
système financier international et donc
d'autres niveau 2
à tous et vulnérable à la fois à
l'endettement du tiers-monde et
particulièrement de l'amérique latine et
à la chute du dollar mais on sait que
les américains accepteront un effort
pour stabiliser leur monnaie que si les
japonais et les allemands acceptent de
leur côté des mesures concrètes pour
relancer leurs économies dans les
milieux bancaires et diplomatique
on ne cachait pas la veille de ce
week-end qu'il sera difficile de
rapprocher les positions
en tout cas ce soir un large accord
n'est pas ont pu en argentine hier soir
près de 12000 personnes ont participé à
une marche aux flambeaux pour protester
contre la loi fixant à demain la date
limite au-delà de laquelle aucune
plainte ne sera plus recevable pour les
violations des droits de l'homme
violations commises sous la dictature
militaire entre 1976 et 1983 les
manifestants veulent obtenir de
nouvelles informations sur le sort des
disparus et que soient condamnés ce qui
les aurait assassiné en millions
soviétique réhabilitation de boris
pasternak l'auteur du docteur jivago
avaient été exclues l'union des
écrivains de l'urss en 1958 décision
annulée il y a quelques jours nouveau
sondage politique en france dans le
journal du dimanche tout d'abord à
paraître demain un sondage ifop +2
points pour monsieur mitterrand 52% et
stabilisation pour monsieur chirac à 39%
et puis dans le magazine le point à
paraître lundi sondage sofres sur la
cohabitation 47% la considèrent comme
plutôt négatif 36% comme plutôt
positives dans les départements bretons
la chute du cours du porc provoque la
colère des agriculteurs ceux ci ont
bloqué les routes du finistère et des
côtes du nord incite la voie ferrée ici
pas de guingamp aujourd'hui hier soir
les éleveurs manifestaient à vannes 2
le morbihan devant la préfecture
quelques-uns se sont affrontés aux
forces de l'ordre en criant des slogans
hostiles au ministre francois guillot
trois crs ont été blessés les
producteurs de porcs entendent continuer
leur mouvement ils dénoncent la baisse
des cours de la viande porcine qui ont
atteint leur niveau le plus bas depuis
1980 voici un exemple d'un éleveur de
porcs dans le finistère celui ci s'est
reconverti volontairement dans cet
élevage sur la foi de recommandation
faite il y a quelques années aujourd'hui
il déchante reportage maryse boino
pierre par pierre gérard mercier bâti sa
reconversion
aidé par ses voisins il construit un
atelier de 88 avant de laisser tomber la
production de lait les quotas ont bloqué
son développement il espère mieux dans
le port secteur laitier à côté de ces 9
à 9 h et avec un quota de 129 mille
litres de lait donc c'est d'investir
dans la production laitière pour vous
encourage à faire du port will et
comment nous nous encourage fortement
faire puisque la région et les abatteurs
et où ils veulent trouver la production
sur place font comme lui ils sont de
plus en plus nombreux dans le morbihan
avant donner le lait pour le port et
tout le monde les y encourage le crédit
agricole qui finance la région qui
accorde une prime importante et bien sûr
les abattoirs qui doivent rentabiliser
l'équipe monde
celui ci a bad 12000 porcs par semaine
s'il veut résister à la concurrence
danoise ou hollandaises
il doit doubler sa capacité résultat il
encourage les jeunes à produire en leur
accordant un prix garanti au risque
d'engorger le marché et de provoquer une
nouvelle chute des cours vont sans doute
chuté avant un ou deux ans puisqu'on est
dans période descendante de prix la
concurrence européenne et très vive et
l'autosuffisance européenne est
actuellement autour sans déboursant faut
pas se faire d'illusion la production
porcine a toujours été comme ça en
alternative avec des courreaux et des
courbes et des périodes de crise qu'on
connaît bien
ah les producteurs de porcs ont
l'habitude oui mais vous aurez une part
de responsabilité dans cette crise
puisque vous encourager la production de
porcs on sait point de responsabilité
dans la production porcine on le sait 1
on avait risque à prendre si on veut que
la production porcine reste en bretagne
c'est clair des producteurs sacrifié par
la crise il y en aura encore
il est vrai qu'en bretagne il suffirait
de 15 mille producteurs avec un cheptel
de 65 truies pour couvrir toute la
production française ils sont deux fois
plus nombreux deux fois trop nombreux
disent certains et c'est le cas dans
d'autres productions
en réalité c'est toute l'agriculture qui
a trop de bras contre l'extension de la
publicité sur l'alcool 14 aux
personnalités scientifiques et médicales
ont décidé soutenir le professeur claude
go qui a démissionné jeudi du haut
comité sur l'alcoolisme ces
personnalités critiques la possibilités
étendues aux chaînes de télévision
privées de diffuser de la publicité pour
les boissons alcoolisées ne dépensant
pas 9 degrés dans un mois les
prospections commençons sur le site de
neuvy bouin près de parthenay dans les
deux sèvres pour étudier la possibilité
d'implantation en sous sol d'un centre
de stockage de déchets nucléaires
cette information que nous vous
révélions dès hier soir a provoqué
beaucoup d'étonnement dans cette région
étonnement sur le secret qui a entouré
la décision de prospection par le
commissariat à l'énergie atomique
reportage patrice blais robert rosier
première mobilisation cet après-midi
appartenait une cinquantaine de membres
du mouvement faire écologistes
autogestionnaire une réunion improvisée
pour refuser la politique du fait
accompli que nous ment faire se propose
pour l'instant de travailler dans ce
sens de la formation parce qu'il est
évident qu'on manque beaucoup à ce
niveau là et au niveau des élus locaux
en particulier de gastines et se propose
d'assurer la formation en gâtine au
niveau 2
l'énergie nucléaire contre laquelle nous
avons toujours lutté mais c'est un
secret pour personne ça et au niveau
maintenant du stockage des déchets
informé parce que jusqu'à présent le
secret a été la règle pas d' enquête
d'utilité publique pas de concertation
avec les élus locaux
les quatre députés des deux sèvres n'ont
même pas été invité par le préfet à la
réunion d'information hier soir dans les
deux cantons concernés
après la surprise le souhait d'ouvrir un
débat
jusqu'en 1995 pas de décisions
définitives 8 en deux phases d'étude
trois forages dans ce massif granitique
et la construction d'un laboratoire
souterrain des 89
si les tests sont bons mais déjà dans la
région des avis négatifs
on est dans un massif armoricain et le
massif qui s'est formée certes qui a
très longtemps conquis constitué de
roches très dur mais un massif qui est
fayez un massif qui est fracturée
laisser fameuse fracture sud armoricaine
nord ouest sud est et qui bouge
il a déjà bougé notre région tout autour
a connu des secousses telluriques
1 la rochelle niort thouars ont eu des
secousses telluriques
en 76 72 la première fois nous menons
une histoire récente 76 81 83
et ces secousses étaient même ressenti à
cerizay cerisaie qui ne se trouve qu'à
une vingtaine trentaine de kilomètres du
site d'implantation à large à ce en
plein coeur de la zone choisie
les 900 habitants voudraient bien en
savoir plus être informés rapidement
pour pouvoir donner leur avis pour
remplacer pierre quilici à la tête de la
direction départemental des polices
urbaines des bouches du rhône c'est
monsieur françois ferrandi qui a été
nommé à marseille il était auparavant
dans le département du var lundi
s'ouvrira à paris devant une cour
d'assises composée uniquement de
magistrats professionnels le procès de
georges ibrahim abdallah chef présumé
des fractions armées révolutionnaires
libanaises des mesures de sécurité sans
précédent ont été décidées georges
ibrahim abdallah n'est loin s'en faut
pas seulement le membre d'un clan
familial résidant au village de couper
yato liban les fractions armées
révolutionnaires libanaises les farl ne
sont sans doute que l'un des chaînons
d'une organisation internationales
pratiquant le terrorisme alors pour
mieux comprendre
je vous propose l'anc est réalisé par
hervé brusini et dominique hertz l'album
de la famille femme ou plutôt les
membres d'identifier des fractions
armées révolutionnaires libanaises selon
les services spéciaux ils seraient près
d'une centaine militants et
sympathisants tous frères cousins neveux
un paisible clocher le berceau du groupe
le village chrétien de coûts béate et à
quelques kilomètres celui d'hendaye cat
ces deux villages auraient déclaré la
guerre à la france en septembre dernier
la france coupable de détenir leur chef
georges ibrahim abdallah à cette version
familiale des femmes à dallas répondu
fond de sa prison il ne manque que les
poules et les oeufs en fait derrière ces
visages se cache une toute autre réalité
celle d'une organisation
politico-militaire
disposant de nombreux soutiens au proche
orient et dans les pays de l'est
georges ibrahim abdallah dirigerait la
branche européenne du groupe
son parcours politique démontre les
multiples amitié que peut avoir un cadre
présumé de l'organisation farl 1972
stage en chine 75 séjour en syrie où il
est remarqué par les conseillers
soviétiques du président assad qu'il
envoie un an à sofia en bulgarie
soixante dix huit l'algérie puis le sud
yémen au liban
ils s'entraînent dans les camps
palestiniens du fplp opérations
spéciales de sélim abou salem avec un
certain carlos que vous allez voir avec
aussi le futur patron de la salle à
l'armée secrète arménienne
hagop hagopian il a été officier de
georges habache qui dirige le front
populaire de libération de la palestine
un pur et dur georges ibrahim abdallah
marxiste intransigeant il a juré de
combattre le sionisme et l'impérialisme
américain victime des farl des
diplomates
deux d'entre eux seront assassinés à
paris
pour être opérationnel l'organisation
militaire doit mettre en place la
logistique un premier bataillon est
envoyé en europe en juin 80 ses membres
jacqueline sbr selim el khoury et
georges ibrahim abdallah à lui seul et
disposent d'au moins cinq passeports 5
identité une algérienne une maltaise une
marocaine une sig et munich et une
libanaise
la bc de la clandestinité c'est aussi
des planques disséminés un peu partout
en europe
appartement pension de famille hôtel en
italie près de rome en espagne dans la
banlieue de madrid
mais aussi en france entre tous et
pied-à-terre les farl ne cesse d'aller à
venir les loyers sont réglés le plus
souvent à l'avant ce grâce à une
multiplication des comptes bancaires
dans tous les pays
il s'agit de brouiller les pistes
impossible de remonter à la source de
financement
l'arrestation d'el mansouri le 6 août 84
permettent aux enquêteurs de découvrir
la filière armement du groupe dans le
train lubiana rome el mansouri
transporte 7 kg 625 de semtex un
explosif tchécoslovaque les pistolets
mitrailleurs retrouvés à paris rue
lacroix viennent eux aussi de
tchécoslovaquie
ils ont été acheminés en pièces
détachées pendant plusieurs semaines à
l'est les farl ont plusieurs points de
chute à belgrade à sofia et à prague
georges ibrahim abdallah d'ailleurs
prévenu ses troupes là-bas leur at il
dit nous avons toutes facilités pour
circuler à l'évidence la famille fal'cie
déterminée soit elle ne peut justifier à
elle seule cette infrastructure
y at il d'autres fractions que celle de
couper y as tu d'autres lieux de
décisions notre enquête permet
d'affirmer qu'une petite ville de la
békaa libanaise a joué un rôle important
dans le fonctionnement de l'organisation
au bout de cette route stora passage
obligé entre damas et beyrouth était la
ville boîtes aux lettres des farl un
électricien pompiste un pâtissier
recevait les messages et les
transmettait au sommet car il ya bien
une structure pyramidale des farl un
directoire de 2 à 3 personnes donne les
ordres
6 à cette fraction comme celle de
georges ibrahim abdallah obéissent
certains de ces groupes sont proches du
hezbollah iranien d'autre de la salle à
bref une organisation complexe
redoutable un adversaire sans doute
sous-estimé enquête hervé brusini de
minutes hier sport athlétisme
aujourd'hui à liévin dans le nord aux
championnats d'europe d'athlétisme en
salle performances impressionnantes du
soviétique robert miens en saut en
longueur regarder robert a mis en est au
sixième essai et il saute 8 mètres 49 le
record du monde de cette spécialité en
salle est détenu par l'américain carl
lewis avec lui m 79 on voit le saut au
ralenti couru m 49 meilleures
performances européennes
dans la nièvre la soviétique robert
emmiyan il y arrête un tir c'est
aujourd'hui à enghien voici le résultat
16 20 et 3 et voilà ce que cela vous
rapporte pour cinq fois en 2005 110 750
pour 16 23 et dans un ordre différent
503 francs 50 et demain pirates dont
soir nous irons à vincennes sur des
pistes enneigées sont si vous le savez
fabuleux vous l'apprendre demain ce sera
le dernier dimanche du meeting d'hiver à
vincennes puisque dès dimanche prochain
vient nous retournerons à auteuil avec
des tirs c'est en obstacle avec des
chevaux d'obstacles et pour clore en
beauté ce meeting d'hiver du trot et
bien une surprise est offerte aux
turfiste demain si vous présentez à
l'hippodrome de vincennes avec votre
magazine habituel de tiercé est bien
ouvert il ya un bon dessus qui vous
donnera l'entrée gratuite sur cet
hippodrome
alors ça vaut vraiment la peine parce
que le programme de courses est superbe
notamment avec la course du tiercé qui
aura lieu dans le prix de paris
la dernière épreuve classique de cette
saison du trou il s'agit d'une course
internationale au 3t qui se dispute sur
une longue distance 3500 mètres et qui
réunit dans un lot de quatorze
concurrents l'élite parmi les trotteurs
et alors il y aura un grand absent ou
ravi ne courra pas ce qui va permettre à
ses adversaires habituels de décès enfin
dans lé v une victoire prestigieuse
alors dans parmi ses adversaires
habituels
cela donnera donc la possibilité de voir
des chevaux comme ogorek et savoir
sortie du pronostic que je propose
maintenant aux grecs en tête de ce
pronostic et porte le numéro 11 suis
defour au taux de 6 son tourbillon
numéro 14 oligo le lis noble à tous le
numéro 12 n'irrigue barbès le neuf et
petits samedi 8 11 6 14 10 12 9 8
merci beaucoup merci pierre être gardées
bien je vous propose une image une photo
c'est dans paris c'est celle de
l'assemblée nationale c'est au palais
bourbon on on rénove l'aspect extérieur
du bâtiment rien des photos on n'a pas
résisté et clichés d'un côté ses propres
de l'autre c'est vieux les travaux temps
du week-end ont été interrompues on a
coupé le palais beaumont 2,55 en
veuillez pas de majorité c'est une photo
symbole comme on dit merci pour la météo
brigitte simonetta demain on va
retrouver de la neige un suppose à terme
il ya enfin un espoir d'amélioration
mais c'est vrai qu'elle ne se fera que
progressivement la nuit la matinée
resteront nuageuse et neigeuses mais en
début d'après-midi regardez là
art des éclaircies belle généreuse
apparaîtront sur toute la moitié ouest
du pays
la perturbation sera rejetée sur le
flanc est vraiment sur le flanc ouest
donne encore de la neige et c'est vrai
aussi sur les pyrénées alors que de
petites éclaircies apparaîtront sur la
côte d'azur et la corse
même s'il ya encore quelques pluies les
températures maximales sont en hausse
nous passons positif de 1 à 6 degrés sur
la moitié nord et de 1 à 10 degrés sur
la moitié sud
demain ce sera le dimanche 22 février
trois minutes de soleil en plus il sa
lèvre à 7h49 se couchera 18h20 est ce
sera la fin isabelle merci visite ce
soir ce sera